I'm here for the carbs being broken
college definitely is a pasta necessity
I don't think I would have made it
through if I didn't eat a lot of pasta I
think I'm gonna do terrible I like to
set expectations up for myself kind of
in the mid-range cuz then no one can be
disappointed just looking at all three
of these pastas they look exactly the
same even the even the smells is the
same
[Music]
the pasta sauce here smells tomatoey
which is a good start that tastes like
pasta this one definitely is like I want
to say it's hearty it doesn't remind me
of college so it must be more specific
if it tastes as if the tomatoes were
plucked underneath the Tuscan Sun I'm
gonna say that's expensive I like this
one definitely contrasting with the
saltiness of this one definitely more
watery in this one to try a little
cheaper I don't know I'm not chef hmm I
want to get it right this is my pride
you know this one is more expensive than
this one I can tell this one tastes a
little bit more Irby okay this one they
barely tasted like anything at all I
feel like I got a hint of tomato okay I
think I got this one okay
can I just can I go ahead and do this so
I'm guessing this is the expensive one
this one I'm like yes this take you back
to my broke days on the dorm room so
this has to be the cheapest one it has
to be I'm gonna go with the expensive
one is the one that I like this was the
cheapest one I'm gonna say I'm just
gonna go ahead and decide this now you
are cheap let's switch these two around
how'd I do
what sure this is the most this is $11
you're paying for nothing oh my god no
no no no this is the cheapest one I'm
very proud of myself like literally this
tasted like nothing it was like olive
oil and tomatoes and in my head I was
like what do fancy people like they just
like being like the quality of the
ingredients is so fresh we just wanted
to let it breathe I still like prego
but I'm very shocked that I was the only
one that got right oh wow
I didn't say I was an expert in this I
just said I'm here for the carbs so I
didn't disappoint anyone wow that blows
my mind that that's blasphemy that's
that's wrong it should be honest it's a
little bland
plant just gives hair